man who was right all over this story
last night from ESPN their MLB insider
Jeff Passan back here in the Rich Eisen
show how you doing Jeff I'm supposed to
be in Kansas City at a parade right
laughs this is your team - right you're
the Chiefs of your team - right they're
my kids team you know it's like I'm that
guy who as he got older not because of
my job right but because I just don't
like stress not rooting for geniuses is
a superior option to rooting for teams
okay
part of that is the fact that I part of
that is the fact that I grew up in
Cleveland and so I never had anything
nice no boy but but but in the end like
I I kind of enjoy sports more because it
doesn't break my heart
all right Jeff well then speaking of
heartbreak and stress why did this have
to happen in Boston why why did why did
why did Mookie Betts have to be sent
away Jeff in your estimation it didn't
it it did not have to happen the reason
that it did happen is because the Red
Sox feel like they have a better chance
of contending over the next five years
if they hit the reset button now and
that they were going to be hemmed in by
their bad decisions of the past and that
those bad decisions we're gonna preclude
them from succeeding and and I think
that's like I listen is that the right
choice is that the fair thing to do that
message you want to send to your fan
base no probably not but the fact is if
they believe the clear path to
contention and to long-term success is
by having some pain right now I think
that's something that's for
Championships in 15 years buys you the
right to do now does it buy you the
right to do with a player like Mookie
Betts there's probably the best Boston
Red Sox and Ted Williams that's that's a
tougher one to argue well I said that's
good you you know for you you just threw
a one out their best Boston Red Sox and
Ted Williams really who's better
Carly Mookie Betts Mookie Betts is a
better player than
carl yastrzemski mookie betts is a
better player than David Ortiz and Manny
Ramirez I mean we're talking about a guy
who over the first you know five plus
six years now of his career is in the
top 10 all-time and Wins Above
Replacement I'm not trying to be nerdy
and I'm not trying to be walking this is
a this is a metric though that's used to
measure generationally like that's the
whole point of it that you can that you
can measure players across generations
and mookie betts a guy with an MVP a guy
with elite elite numbers every year who
does not have a weakness and I mean does
not have a weakness he's a guy who had a
high strikeout air it doesn't strikeout
he's a guy who walks he's a guy who
steals faces at an extraordinarily good
clip he hits her average he hits for
power there is no better defensive right
fielder than him he is the total package
and so yeah I think he is better than
the Hall of Famers that the Red Sox have
had and I think he is clearly on the
path to the Hall of Fame themselves so
I'm I will then say this ask this
question next to you Jeff Passan that
normally when this happens in any sport
and it's difficult to comprehend or
understand the player perhaps might not
want to be where the team wanted him to
be so they sent him away or couldn't run
the risk or etc and so forth is that an
undercurrent here that that was going on
do you think I think Mookie Betts wants
to be a free agent and you know what I
don't blame them for that
I don't blame somebody who goes into a
system where for seven years his
employer is whoever you know Jurassic or
whoever has emerged trades for them you
don't have any choice in the matter and
if you believe in yourself like he does
and you believe that you're going to go
out there and have a typical standard
Mookie Betts type season he's looking at
rich at a minimum of three hundred fifty
million dollars and a contract that
could well be in excess of four hundred
million dollars and if the Red Sox are
not going to offer that right
now and incentivize him to to lose that
choice like that choice is worth a lot
of money to a player the ability to say
this is in whom I believe this is where
I want to live this is the organization
that I want to tether myself to if
you're not going to overspend for that
choice you're not going to get the
player so then explain those luxury tax
in all this too because you know this
works and whether the doctors are
throwing caution to the wind and and
because that's clearly what's at play
here too Jeff can you no question about
it so so here's the luxury tax threshold
this year is 208 million dollars over
the last two seasons the Red Sox have
been in excess of it the more times
you're over the threshold the harsher
the penalties for being so gay and and
this is not just a money thing this also
has to do with draft picks and and
potentially international signing money
that being said rich the luxury tax
threshold should not be the driving
force for trading a franchise player and
if it is and if the Red Sox publicly
come out and say that it was then they
are spinning and that is something that
is forth that should not believe is it
part of the package yes absolutely
was the greater driving force the fear
that Mookie Betts was going to leave
after a 2020 season in which the Red Sox
finished third behind the New York
Yankees and the Tampa Bay Rays and that
the best they were gonna get for him was
a fourth-round draft pick yes that was
the driving force of this and you know
what I get it I get it because they're
gonna have a right fielder now it's for
do those who's gonna be there for five
years and they're gonna have a guy in
brew star grotto who as long as his
shoulder holds up is either going to be
a really good starter at worse they're
closer so you know what they're there is
from the value perspective if you're
looking at this strictly in a vacuum the
Red Sox came out looking like bandits
you know the future value
placed on Alex Verdugo is $70,000,000
non grata role is 40 or 50 million
dollars if we're again getting very
nerdy on this and mookie betts his value
if he has an average year this year is
surplus I was going to be about 70
million dollars and they shed David
prices contract so in a vacuum this
actually is a good and productive deal
for the Boston Red Sox it just doesn't
feel that way and I completely
understand why well part of the reason
why to Jeff Passan of ESPN on the Honda
inside a report is that usually when you
trade a player like this you see three
or four names if somebody is either in
there they're their late teens or really
early 20s and I know you mentioned grata
role by the way it would have been much
better if it was pronounced the way I
did at the top of the show greater role
because that does sound like what Red
Sox fans are taking to get rid of their
injured indigestion today normally
normally you see a whole host of
prospects is the reason why we don't see
that because bets is in a walk year and
the Dodgers were using that to their
advantage to hold on to some of their
prospects Jeff a hundred percent why
when you trade a guy was just one year
to go I mean you've you know you've lost
a playoff run that you could have gotten
last year if you had decided to deal
with and we're gonna see that this year
potentially with Francisco Lindor or
with Chris Bryant you know two guys who
have two years before they hit free
agency if their teams want to cash in as
best as possible they will wait until
July 31st and we'll trade him this year
now it's possible that the Cubs are
contending and that they're not going to
trade them that's reasonable it's
possible that the Indians are content
they're not going to trade the door and
again that's okay you know you can
explore doing it in the offseason
potentially but if you really want to
get the most out of a guy who's getting
near free agency trading him with two
playoff runs left is the best way to
leverage it so let's talk about the Los
Angeles teams then in a few minutes we
have with you left here Jeff Dodgers got
to feel great about their lineup what
about their their pitching staff I guess
they feel like they got the veteran in
price who did have a tremendous playoff
run when the Red Sox wanted all that
what do you think about the Dodgers
chances here no I mean David prices
david prices stuff is down no question
about it you know he's not the same
country once was he's in his mid 30s now
and it's gonna be interesting to see how
much he can adjust to diminish stuff
which still for left enter is actually
pretty good you know average fastball
around 92 miles per hour which he was
the hardest throwing left knee in
baseball for like half a decade so you
know 92 is nothing to sneeze at but the
big question with the Dodgers is their
pitching you know they want to Guerra
call this offseason rich like they were
willing to go to 300 million dollars for
him the Yankees were just willing to go
much higher and he wanted to go play in
New York and so I I don't think there's
a problem having Walker Buehler pitch
opening day he's a guy who's gonna be in
cyan contention this year I don't think
there's a problem having Clayton
Kershaw's your number 2 starter but it's
gonna be interesting to see how he
adjusts as well to diminish velocity and
you know they have Alex wood coming off
of an injury they could go with a who
you aureus or Dustin May at the back end
of their rotation like they've got debts
there and their bullpen again another
question mark but they've got young arms
and they've got prospects who if they
really need you they can go trade to
fortify their pitching staff come July
and then this is all about this is all
about October for them rich sure you
know April through September for the
Dodgers is is going to be a question not
of will they win the National League
West but of how many games will they
wait is this a team that after a hundred
six win season adding a guy who's
arguably the second best player in
baseball could 110 115 even more
potentially I don't think that's out of
the realm of possibility I think I think
the floor I think unless there are just
catastrophic injuries across that
organization the floor is gonna be a
hundred wins for the Dodgers so I mean
and now when you say it's about October
for the Dodgers you're basically saying
it's got to be about getting to October
for the Angels because the
number of times here best player oh my
god if we saw Mike Trout in October the
whole country needs to see him and it's
only happened once in 2014 do we finally
get it do you think I mean with Peterson
being at it's a trend owned and
obviously Madden pushing the button
zoton e's apparently getting ready to
pitch and hit i mean this is it right
Jeff I'll tell you their lineup when
jock the joc pederson deal goes through
has a chance to be absolutely scary
you've got Peterson you've got Trout
you've got just enough then Anthony
Rendon a third base Angeles and Simmons
David Fletcher can hit at second base I
mean they've got guys up and down that
lineup who are really really good their
pitching staff is a problem and and they
they just have to hope that some of
these guys they've got I'm one-year
deals like Julio Teheran or Dylan Bundy
that they get something out of him that
Otani can come back and he's not going
to go out there and throw 200 innings
for you but if you can manage his
workload this year coming off a Tommy
John surgery and get those potentially
dominant performances that he has shown
in the past and his rookie year then you
know they can go out and get another
starter at the deadline which they
certainly can suddenly they are a team
that can be in contention but let's not
forget rich the the Oakland A's are in
their division and the Houston Astros
are in their division and the Chicago
White Sox a Minnesota Twins and
Cleveland Indians are in their league
and so are the the New York Yankees and
Tampa Bay Rays even the Boston Red Sox
who still believe that they can be a
playoff contender we're talking like
nine teams with playoff aspirations here
and and you could throw the Texas
Rangers in there as well two-thirds of
the league right now thinks that it can
be a playoff contender so the Angels I
think in the end need more if they want
one of those spots alright before I let
you go Jeff asked the poll question of
Jeff Passan today Chris Brockman I'm
keen to know what his answer would be go
for it hi Jeff we're looking way ahead
who wins the World Series this year
Dodgers Yankees or the field
well that's a good one I will always
take the field just because it's the
right bet but if you were to ask me name
a World Series winner
I'd say Dodgers Dodgers okay Rogers
Dodgers why do you say that to Jeff with
Gary Cole going games 147 I mean I kind
of like that the the chances there no
yeah and the unlucky and the Yankees
bullpen is better than daughters there's
there's no question about that but I see
in a Dodgers opening day lineup seven
all-stars and the two guys who are not
all stars are Gavin lux who the top five
prospect in baseball right now and Will
Smith who by the end of the year I think
is going to be a top five catcher in
baseball this is a dominant dominant
potentially historically good team that
we're looking at alright Jeff Passan
appreciate the time let's chat again
soon great spot as always thanks to the
call better that's Jeff Passan at Jeff
Passan on Twitter I follow him you
should too for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR Live or download
the Rich Eisen show app